let me ask you this man obviously uh
rest in peace the whole vein man um who
passed away last year from heart attack
do you after when you lose somebody like
that
did it make you regret any of the stuff
that you put into the air about hovane
no I didn't because I I played nothing
but facts into the above me which you
don't what you don't know about vain
you don't know the real you don't know
the real him and just like a lot of
people don't I was on math half a
podcast and I had to correct somebody
they were saying yeah man did you do
anything for for his kids what what you
don't know is I gave him the name Jose
which you might not know is that I
bought them into the industry you made I
know that okay now
what you don't know is your relationship
with him comes through me 100 right what
you don't know is he didn't [__] with
you
it was me saying nah I [__] with Kev you
bugging but Jose knew how to play the
game I like I said I'm real and uncut I
don't pretend to [__] with people when I
don't I don't if I [__] with you I
genuinely do if I don't I just don't
there's no beef no I'm personal I don't
he knows how to put on his smiling face
that's why I say hey you'll be at the
Forefront be the manager now did he grow
the [__] with you later on you haven't
said me and him at like hours and hours
of conversations for the last five years
so now here go the thing let me tell you
when when the accountant is real it's
countless people who had hours and hours
of conversations with him they ain't
countless peoples who had hours of
conversation with me because it is it's
worth more it's not just giving to
anybody it's giving to people who I
genuinely care for so but the reason why
I bring that up is because obviously I'm
gonna tell you I don't regret anything
that's the truth
you're his kids Godfather correct yeah
one of them one of his kids Godfathers
and my thing is is when there's that
level of like love at a certain point
right because I think there was like a
certain point in time where you put out
like a almost like a podcast it was like
a 30 minute thing where you were talking
about what happened and you were talking
about Jose and I think it was a check on
the dope boy Cherry project yeah
um and it was like kind of like you
talking for like it was about a half
hour I was just talking about the whole
initial part of me meeting them because
like like I said I deal with facts I was
talking about how when I I got a a
management deal with butcher Lewis God
blessed today real man he put me on with
rap and they say yo I'm gonna give you
this much money a week and I said why
can you take some of that money out of
my money and give my partners uh K cash
and hold vein which got nothing to do
with music I'm just putting them on we
riding around selling music yo can you
give them 300 a week each 600 not out of
your money but out of my money I did
that that's how I sacrificed for my
people so for somebody that I did that
for they owe me more than that for
somebody I helped get off the projects
they owe me more than that for somebody
who I gave a name to I put this this was
a dream it is I put them on with a dream
I didn't but it was manages that I could
have went with and and like most people
do they switch managers they diss the
people that they came up with I never
did that even with god with money Nails
Chris Lighty I'm like yo listen
I'm gonna [__] with y'all but my dog
gotta be with me that's real loyalty
when when most managers well nah it's
only me or nobody you know this from
being in the game but I'm like yo listen
it's 20 but my dog who got no experience
and don't know [__] he got to be with me
or else I ain't [__] with you that's
real loyalty that most people won't do
and and for somebody that does that they
owe me more they owe me more than that
than to
have a we got an understanding of
um I got charged with four with four
Council weapons possession attempted
murder and they was lingering the murder
of my friend Banger my real friend right
on over over my head I'm talking about
bangers my real man like when when he
come home from jail I'm bailing them out
we at the crib with a chef having [__]
there oh vane ain't there you feel me
it's a fact so my thing is is yeah I'm
saying they owe me more than that to
where if you and your guys right here I
don't know everybody's position but they
here he's doing his thing he's doing his
thing
bless you see y'all running around you
get caught with a gun illegally I don't
know the dynamic y'all relationship but
I feel like
one of your guys should be like yo Kev
keep [__] going I'm gonna take this gun
charge I ain't gonna sit for long just
hold me down financially because if you
go to jail all this [__] stops right
real [__] so now imagine coming from the
street knowing that and now you into
music making more money and being more
successful and the game plan is hey yo
listen y'all [__] nobody else help me
with no money for Bill no lawyer no
nothing it's cool I got that it's all I
need
I'm gonna fight this attempted murder
and I'm gonna fight this gun this other
gun charge y'all just fight the gun
charges I'm paying for the lawyer and
everything I didn't pay for a lawyer
with uh with hope before and beat it
John Stella my same attorney I had beat
a gun charge for him spanked it hey I
just need y'all to do that
all right bet he I'll call Wolfie on the
phone who said in court that yo if they
when they finally when they brought up
that they caught the guns in there in
court he said to I'm gonna take the
other gun because that's what we do
that's what I did for him that's what
I'm gonna do for anybody in a higher
position that's holding us down you know
what I'm saying so I guess for them to
act funny all of a sudden when it's time
and I hold the end of the debugging that
ain't 100 to me that's my thing is
that's like hoven's passed away like
he's not here anymore you know what I
mean and like well we spoke after that
we spoke after that we we spoke on
multiple occasions I seen them and you
know it is what it is that don't take
back the facts so my thing is this is
like you know there's [__] that's online
now that like his kids are gonna have to
grow up and like you know when they look
up their pops on that [__] YouTube
bro it's it's the truth
you don't regret anything that you said
about him
if I had made up stuff and I came up
with slander and [__] and cool but I
said [__] that was the truth they they
said I was on drugs he said I was
bugging he told somebody he had to get
away before he had to put hands on me
man the [__] were we you put hands on
choice I don't [__] like these are the
narratives that they pushed so that they
wouldn't look crazy when everybody's
like well why did you leave Ave why
wasn't you there we come from if you
come somewhere with somebody you leave
with them you don't leave your friends I
don't give a [__] if you hear shots in
the other room and your peoples went in
that room to go to the bathroom you run
the [__] there you don't walk out the
door I got to get out of here you go see
him make sure they good that's where we
come from and when the pressure was on
they didn't stand on that so if his kids
if my kids got to see [__] online about
me that shoe they gotta see it the
[__] lady who uh said Emmett Till
looked at her just died people don't
give a [__] right she should have never
said that [__] the [__] could burn in
hell good riddance I just think like
it's you taking it it's all about
perspective it's all about how you feel
and you can't ever pacify somebody
feelings cause I was there Ground Zero
of the Betrayal you that's like me
saying if something happens with you and
my wife can't leave it alone well I
think that's Ground Zero again you talk
about perspective I think like talking
to him there's like a different
perspective on my way his you got you
but then you have the truth bro I only
dealing the truth I'm telling you you
don't know this person how I dealt with
this how everything that I said about
these people I show video evidence to
prove it yeah everything here's a fact
that you can ask you can ask yourself
you have to ask him I can't ask him
you don't even have to ask him you ask
yourself because this I only deal in
fact no made up [__] hey yo listen ho
average your man right y'all came about
the money together he put you on he did
everything for you why why did you leave
him and take all those guns
fighting for his life this is a
ridiculous relief I can't even there's
no point in talking to my guy's dead so
what are we even talking about being day
no it's my guy Kevin he didn't [__] with
you I'm the one that made him [__] with
you so when he came to the point would
you where you say some [__] like yo Ave
is controversial I don't know if
start all this [__] and you having
loyalty bro I'm telling you I have no
reason to lie whether I leave whether I
do this interview leaving now I'm still
gonna be rich bro I'm still gonna be me
I'm still gonna drop an album and I'm
still gonna go top 10 and billboard and
I'm gonna do number one and number two
independent and I'm still gonna live I'm
still gonna be at the floor see some
fights my life's still gonna be good I'm
telling you real life [__] bro you don't
even play my records and it don't matter
I'ma still be good but I'm telling you
just for Life moving on be loyal and and
truthful and hold it down for the people
that would really hold it down for you
and don't ask him he's dead you can't
but ask yourself why wouldn't somebody
do that these are the facts why was Adam
fighting for his life in a room by
himself things could have turned out
different so why didn't I get left to
take all of these guns you went unless
the converse the conversation
the conversations that you guys had
before he passed were you guys in a
positive place because you posted like a
rest in peace post Forum I mean yeah we
was cool but I'm I'm gonna tell you with
the last conversation about the last
conversation we were supposed to get up
and he kind of Spun me like I've seen
him in person come here fat boy let's
talk [__] like you know what I'm saying
like because I saw your post and I was
like well [__] like I don't know I don't
know if this was the energy like it was
a positive post but like when he was
alive you had a lot of negative energy
uh towards no that's not you I I spoke I
spoke to him
we had a situation where we had to speak
about some business but because you guys
I mean look when you guys were like
[__] Damon and Hove you know what I'm
saying it was like Chili Avenue but I'm
saying like in terms of like yeah we was
like I never wouldn't be like no other
man but what I'm saying is
wait you can speak to somebody and [__]
two troops can be one
you they could have done all of this
[__] and you can still feel for
their loss that picture that I showed
you 100 that that video two things can
be true that that video that I put up
that's before rap [__] that's
freestyling and my mom's basement Studio
that I built and we counting my drug
money you hear me that I put them on to
go hey come on like I'm the type of
friendly but yo I'm going by these
bricks you can put in with me
no I don't want to put in I well I'll
get the bricks and whatever you sell
give me half but you got the opportunity
to come in and be a whole partner that's
before rap that's before anything that's
when you in Tampa not even know I
definitely agree that you you can you
can agree on two things can be true at
the same time right so you saying Were
you invited to the funeral
invited I found out first and I ain't no
people get invited to funerals who the
[__] is invited to a funeral I've never
been invited to a funeral in my life I
mean I mean that's nuts to be invited to
a funeral yes you [__] grieve me so I
wouldn't invite nobody to a funeral
you had to go to court that day right I
had to go to court that day but not even
that like
bro I found out hovine died before you
knew I actually I actually think I might
have found out I found out like the
night it happened I found out yeah I
found it the night before everybody
called me and we're like hey just so you
know it's happened
right now I got a call as well all right
well then there you go that's when I
found out he died yeah but you don't get
invited to a funeral at all you could
just go I know people that didn't even
like mutual friends of us that don't
even
they didn't even speak to him whatever
they went to the funeral they know
funeral was open invite when you lose
somebody like him does it make you like
kind of maybe want to patch some [__] up
with someone like Lido
[__] no I don't leave the bro for what
time is it what time will y'all be here
one all right well look the new album is
out yeah new albums out God is getting
the paper straight stand how often are
you dropping the podcast well every
every week we got episodes bro with God
believe in God spread love and Destroy
hate that's the message to everybody
spread love and Destroy hate hate is a
cancer